a group of friends wondered how much
faster they could snap their fingers on
one hand versus the other hand very
important question in life each person
snapped their fingers with their
dominant hand for 10 seconds and their
non-dominant hand for 10 seconds for
where if you're right-handed right hand
would be your dominant hand if you were
left-handed left hand would be your
dominant hand each participant flipped a
coin to determine which hand they would
use first because if you always used
your dominant hand first maybe you're
tired by the time you're doing your
non-dominant hand or there's something
else so here it's it's random which one
you use first here are the data for how
many snaps they performed with each hand
the difference for each participant and
summary statistics and this is actually
real data from the Khan Academy content
team and so you see for each of the
participants for Jeff right over here he
was able to do 44 snaps in ten seconds
on his dominant hand which is impressive
more than I think I could do and he was
even able to do 35 on his non-dominant
hand and so the difference here the
dominant hand - the non-dominant was
nine and then they tabulated this data
for all five members now they also
calculated summary statistics for them
but this is the really interesting thing
right over here this is the difference
between the dominant and the
non-dominant hand and so what they did
here the mean difference what they did
is they took this row right over here
and they calculated the mean which they
got to be 6.8 and then they calculated
the standard deviation of these
differences right over here which they
got to be approximately one point six
four and then we are asked create and
interpret a 95% confidence interval for
mean difference in number of snaps for
these participants so pause this video
see if you can make some headway here
see if you could think about how to
approach this so what's interesting here
is we're not trying to construct a
confidence interval for just the mean
number of snaps for the dominant hand or
the mean number of snaps for the
non-dominant hand we're constructing a
95% confidence interval for a mean
difference now you might
you know I have two different samples
here and then this third sample is or
this third data is somehow constructed
from these other two but one way to
think about it this is matched pairs
design so in a matched pair design what
you do is for each participant for each
member in your sample you will make them
do the control and the treatment so for
example you could view the control as
how many they can do in the dominant
hand in ten seconds and the treatment is
how many they can do in the non-dominant
hand and in matched pairs design you're
really concerned about the difference
and so it you can really view this as is
you just have one sample size of five
for which you are calculating the
difference for each member of that
sample and the standard deviation across
that entire sample now before we
calculate the confidence interval let's
just remind ourselves some of our
conditions that we like to think about
when we are constructing confidence
intervals the first condition we think
about is whether our sample is random
now if we were trying to make some type
of judgment about all human beings and
they're snapping ability this would not
be a random sample these people all work
at Khan Academy maybe somehow in our
interview process we select for people
who snap particularly well but whatever
inferences we make we can say hey this
is roughly true about this group of
friends now the next condition we want
to think about is the normal condition
now there's a couple of ways to think
about it if we had sample size of 30 or
larger the central limit theorem says
okay the distribution the sampling
distribution would be roughly normal the
sampling distribution of the sample
means but obviously our sample size is
much smaller than that one way to think
about it we could just plot our data
points and see whether they are seem to
be skewed in any way and if we just do a
little dot plot right over here we could
say let's say make this 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 & 9 so we have one data point where
the difference was nine one data point
where the difference is 5 one data point
where the difference is 8 one data point
where the difference is 6 and another
data point where the difference is
six and so this doesn't look massively
skewed in any way our mean difference
was right over here is about six point
eight it looks roughly symmetric so we
can feel okay about this normal
distribution this isn't the best study
that one could conduct this is obviously
a small sample size it's not random of
the entire population but maybe we could
go with it also when you think about
biological processes like how well
someone snaps which is a product of a
lot of things happening in a human body
and it's the sum of many many processes
those things also tend to have a roughly
normal distribution but I won't go into
too much depth there but all of these
things once again this isn't a super
robust study but this is a fun thing for
friends to do what they have nothing
else to do all right now the third one
is independence and this one actually we
can feel pretty good about because just
difference right over here really
shouldn't impact David's difference or
David's difference really shouldn't
impact Kim's difference especially if
they're not observing each other and
let's just say for sake of argument that
they did it all independently in a
closed room with a independent observer
so they weren't trying to get
competitive or something like that but
needless to say this isn't super robust
study but we can still calculate a 95%
confidence interval so how do we do that
well we've done this so many times our
confidence interval would be our sample
mean so it would be the mean of our
difference the mean of our difference
plus or minus now we don't know the
population standard deviation so we're
going to use our sample standard
deviation and if you're using a sample
standard deviation and this confidence
interval is all about the mean and so
our critical value here is going to be
based on a t-table on the T statistic
and they're going to multiply that times
the sample standard deviation of the
differences divided by the square root
of our sample size divided by the square
root of 5 now we know most of this data
here and let me just write it down over
here we know the mean the sample mean
right over here is 6 point 8 so it's
going to be 6 point 8 plus or minus and
now what will be our critical value here
well we want to have a 95% confidence
interval and what's our
of freedom well it's one less than our
sample size so our degrees of freedom
right over here is equal to four and so
we're you ready to use a tea table so
this is a truncated tea table that I
could fit on my screen here and so
there's a couple of ways to think about
it here they actually give us the
confidence level and the reason why that
corresponds to a tail probability of
0.025 is if you take the middle 95% of a
distribution
you're going to have 2.5 percent on
either and that's going to be your tail
probability so that's all that's going
on over there so we're going to be in
this column right over here and which
degree of freedom do we use or degrees
of freedom well it's going to be 4
degrees of freedom our sample size is 5
5 minus 1 is 4 so this is going to be
our critical value to point 7 7 6 so we
have 2 point 7 7 6
as our critical value and then times our
sample standard deviation well the
sample standard deviation for our
differences right over here is 1 point 6
4 and then we're going to divide that by
the square root of our sample size so
the square root of our sample size where
you wrote a 5 in there sometimes I just
write it end there and so what is this
going to be equal to first let's
calculate just the margin of error right
over here so this is going to be 2 point
7 7 6 times 1 point 6 4 divided by the
square root of 5 and we get a margin of
error of approximately two point zero
three six so this is going to be six
point eight plus or minus two point zero
three six it's approximately equal to
that where this is our margin of error
and if we actually wanted to write out
the interval we could just take six
point eight minus this and six point
eight plus that so let's do that again
with the calculator so six point eight
minus two point zero three six is equal
to four point seven six four so our
confidence interval starts at
or 0.76 for approximately and it goes to
let's see that can actually do this one
in my head if I add two point zero three
six to six point eight that is going to
be eight point eight three six now how
would we interpret this confidence
interval right over here one way to
interpret it is to say that we are 95%
confident that this interval captures
the true mean difference in snaps for
these friends we could also say that
there appears to be a difference in the
mean number of snaps since zero is not
captured in this interval and since the
entire interval is above zero zero is
not captured here and it's above zero it
seems that this group right over here
this group of friends at Khan Academy
can snap faster with their dominant
hands